welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar the efficacy of
high CBD low THC for better outcomes in
medical marijuana treatment programs it
is presented by Ruth Bertrand LPN a
member of the American cannabis Nurses
Association a C and an a a member of
Delaware Normal and the Delaware
cannabis advocacy Network and a medical
marijuana patient advocate and
consultant my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's leverage is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producers educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits and now without further ado
please join me in welcoming Ruth
Bertrand I will now turn the
presentation over to her hello and thank
you for attending my webinar on the
efficacy of high CBD low THC for better
patient outcomes in medical marijuana
treatment programs at the end of this
presentation there is a YouTube video
for you to watch on CBD THC just click
on the far left of your screen today's
learning objectives are understanding
CBD THC ratios in medical marijuana and
using high CBD low THC cannabis products
to treat disease processes
there are at least a hundred and
thirteen cannabinoids and this webinar
is going to address two of them that
work together to provide our bodies with
synergy that's high CBD low THC strains
of marijuana and how they help patients
who use them CBD and THC interact with
each other and by using them together
patients may find that the effects of
THC are lessened but prolonged there are
many patients who just cannot tolerate
the effects of THC while there are many
others who smoke THC in order to relax
another factor to consider is the way in
which marijuana is consumed such as
smoking tinctures edibles and topicals
cannabinoids are better absorbed by the
body when ingested on a full stomach CBD
is intrinsically safe and there is no
way to tell if you have had enough as
with THC you would just be too high
combining CBD and THC causes a reduction
in the psychoactive effects of THC CBD
will also help to lessen the sedative
and appetite appetite inducing effects
this is known as the entourage effect
where both compounds work best when
they're used together these two
molecules are a perfect complement to
each other in January of this year the
medical value of cannabis was recognized
by the world who health organization the
therapeutic potentials of cannabis and
cannabinoids has been acknowledged for
the first time since 1954 by this group
they have proposed new international
scheduling moving towards efforts to
increase the potential for countries to
provide legal safe access for medical
use of cannabis and its research the
organization accepted the public's
comments on the scheduling of marijuana
until March 14th of this year
I of course posted my thoughts on the
website and implored them to seriously
consider removing marijuana as a
schedule 1 drug
cannabidiol or CBD is a component of the
anibus plant that may have enormous
therapeutic potential although it
doesn't make people feel high like THC
CBD is causing quite a buzz among
scientists health professionals and
medical marijuana patients who are using
CBD products to treat a wide variety of
conditions including chronic pain cancer
Crohn's diabetes rheumatoid arthritis
PTSD cardiovascular disease anxiety and
antibiotic resistant infections multiple
sclerosis schizophrenia and more
academic research centers around the
world are currently studying effects of
CBD on these and other ailments
scientists refer to CBD as a promiscuous
compound because it confers therapeutic
benefits in many different ways while
tapping into how we function
physiologically and biologically on a
deep level extensive preclinical
research and some clinical studies have
shown that CBD have strong antioxidant
anti-inflammatory anticonvulsant
antidepressant antipsychotic antitumoral
and neuro protective qualities
cannabidiol appears to change gene
expression and may be helpful in
removing beta amyloid plaque which is
the hallmark of Alzheimer's from brain
cells
what is THC CBD and THC are the power
couple of cannabis therapeutics they
appear to work best together
for example CBD is believed to boost th
C's pain-killing and anti-cancer
properties
CBD can also lessen the side effects of
too much THC including anxiety and rapid
heartbeat relaxing but not intoxicating
is how some people describe CBD rich
cannabis products CBD and THC both
appear to stimulate neurogenesis the
creation of new brain cells and adult
mammals which may prove helpful for
stroke and Parkinson's patients products
made from industrial hemp that contain
little or no THC are currently being
market widely but recent scientific
studies suggest that the products made
from hemp or synthetic CBD
maybe less effective therapeutically
than cannabis based medicines because
they lack critically secondary
cannabinoids and other medicinal
compounds that interact with CBD and THC
to enhance their therapeutic benefits
scientists call this the entourage
effect numerous cannabis compounds have
medicinal attributes but the therapeutic
impact of the whole plant cannabis seems
to be greater than the sum of its parts
it still seems that patients are looking
for the most part the high THC low CBD
products but I feel as a nurse that they
would be better suited to choose the
high CBD low THC products for medicinal
purposes it just seems like the high CBD
has more benefits for most medical
patients CBD binds with CBD receptors in
the body and helps to regulate appetite
pain management and immune system
function such as inflammation Harlequin
sweet and sour widow Stephen Hawking
Kush ac/dc canna tonic and Pennywise are
some of the most popular and common
strains of high CBD flour it is not so
much that CBD makes you feel good
but that it makes you not feel bad and
since it's a cap cannabinoid coming from
the cannabis plant it is often confused
with THC which is a psychoactive
compound and people expect to feel high
from it it's imperative that we educate
patients as well as the public to the
fact that being high as they say on
cannabis cannot be compared to being
intoxicated on alcohol or to the ill
effects of most pharmaceuticals such as
opiates benzodiazepines antipsychotics
and antidepressants with a CBD high you
won't feel sedated or groggy for most
people it takes about 20 minutes to feel
the effects of CBD when taken on an
empty stomach if taking on a full
stomach it's about an hour there are
many studies that find inflammation as
the main contributing factor in
problems of the brain such as anxiety
brain fog depression autism a DD and
ADHD CBD oil is proving to be an
effective treatment for social anxiety
and is naturally calming side effects
from cannabis are dose dependent high
CBD low THC therapy should always start
with low doses increasing slowly so that
the patient can find their individual
dose and unwanted effects can be avoided
CBD also interacts with THC by taking
CBD and THC together individuals may
find that the effects of THC are
tempered but prolonged slightly some
people can hardly tolerate any THC the
wide range of reaction to THC rich
cannabis may be influenced by genetic
factors that may be one of the reasons
why some people find THC rich cannabis
to be unpleasant while hundreds of
millions smoked it to relax this genetic
variant exists among 20% of people in
the European and Middle Eastern
population of Caucasians meaning one in
five or THC averse less than 10 percent
of Africans have this genetic variant
and among Asians it's less than 5%
how does CBD benefit the human body
CBD shows promise for helping to subdue
the symptoms of anxiety which most of us
about 30% suffer from it produces
effects via molecular molecular pathways
CBD enhances activation of serotonin to
impede disorders such as anxiety it has
been found to be a natural anxiety
calmer and works very well in the
treatment of social anxiety in addition
to fighting inflammation in the body CBD
oil may reduce anxiety by directly
affecting the brain studies have found
that CBD actually lowers activity in the
amygdala and increases prefrontal cortex
activation to parts of the brain
involved in anxiety
is also evidence that CBD is able to
activate new neurons in the hippocampus
this accent activates CBD 1 receptors
which has a positive balancing impact on
gaba and glutamate levels associated
with reducing anxiety doctors often
advise people with chronic anxiety to
avoid cannabis as THC can trigger or
amplify feelings of anxiousness and
paranoia which is true I think for a lot
of people that paranoia is definitely a
side effect of a high THC product
however authors of a review from neuro
therapeutics found that CBD may help to
reduce anxiety in people with certain
related disorders according to the
review CBD may reduce anxiety related
behaviors and people with conditions
such as PTSD general anxiety disorder
panic disorder social anxiety disorder
and obsessive-compulsive disorder the
authors noted that current treatments
for these disorders can lead to
additional symptoms and side effects
which can cause some people to stop
taking them no further definitive
evidence currently leaked CBD to adverse
effects and the authors called for
further studies of the compound as a
treatment for anxiety anxiety and
depression or pathologies affect human
beings and may aspects of life including
social life productivity and health CBD
is a compound of the cannabis plant with
great psychiatric potential including
use as an antidepressant studies
involving animal models performing a
variety of experiments on the
above-mentioned disorder such as the
forced swimming test the elevated plus
maze and the global conflict test
suggest the CBD exhibited an
anti-anxiety and antidepressant effect
in the animal models discussed
experiments with CBD demonstrated non
activation of neuroreceptor cb1 and cb2
PTSD or post-traumatic stress disorder
is a psychological ailment that is
beginning to gain the attention of CBD
research
PTSD exhibits and individuals who have
experienced trauma and/or abuse in their
lifetime the disorder is most noteworthy
and military veterans and accident
survivors CBD has proven beneficial in
relation to PTSD as it reportedly helps
curb manifestations of both depression
and anxiety without the debilitating
side effects of pharmaceuticals CBDs
effectiveness concerning PTSD is evident
in the fact that states like Arizona are
now recognizing PTSD as an ailment that
warrants legal access to medical
marijuana CBD has the ability to lower
cortisol levels at slow down muscle
growth
the reason body builders need to work
regularly to maintain continued growing
their form is because our bodies do not
grow muscles naturally in fact our
endocrine system produces catabolic
hormones such as cortisol which break
down muscle mass in order to use the
amino acids for other functions to
counter this dilemma someone who wishes
to build muscle would have to take
catabolic supplements and this is where
CBD comes into play studies show that
cannabidiol can lower the number of
catabolic hormones in the human body
meaning that muscle game won't be lost
so quickly and it makes it easier to
gain muscle mass quicker keep in mind
that CBD should not be taken with
caffeine at least not for this purpose
caffeine promotes the production of
catabolic hormone so it would only
counter the effects of CBD many medical
patients tell us that marijuana helps
their pain neuropathic pain also known
as nerve pain is a unique type of pain
that is caused by injured dysfunction or
irritated nerves the pain tends to be
chronic and severe with no known cure or
remedy the individual is left to try
numerous strategies to try to find
something that works some of the most
common sources of neuropathy include
diabetes injury cancer infections
alcoholism and autoimmune disorders
have been human clinical trials that
support benefits of THC and CBD for
nerve pain there have been fewer studies
examining just CBD in an animal study
researchers found that oral
supplementation of CBD led to
improvements in neuropathic pain in rats
back pain is one of the most common
forms of both acute and chronic pain
acute back pain tends to call be caused
by an injury such as a fall or by
lifting something heavy chronic back
pain is that which lasts more than three
months and is often caused by a ruptured
or bulging disc author itis osteoporosis
scoliosis or nerve pain some back pain
is partly caused by inflammation and
numerous preclinical animal studies have
found benefits of CBD for inflammation
three possible reduction in both nerve
and inflammatory pain CBD may help
relieve back pain the main mechanism by
which CBD is thought to help mediate
pain is by reducing inflammation largely
by blocking inflammatory mediators it is
also believed to potentiate glycan
receptors which help to regulate pain at
the spinal level this suppresses both
neuropathic and inflammatory pain CBD
has been found to exhibit enhancements
in treating pain both when used on its
own and when used in combination with
THC when used alone CBD is largely best
for inflammatory pain such as that
caused by arthritis or injuries in one
animal study on arthritis pain it was
found that the topical application of
CVD led to a reduction in inflammation
and pain another animal study found that
CBD helps to reduce neuropathic pain
through the suppression of chronic
inflammation CBD does not directly bind
to the receptors found in the
endocannabinoid system
so rather works to modulate the effects
of endocannabinoids found naturally in
our bodies as well as working as a
cb-one antagonist when searching for the
best cannabis strains for pain relief
you will first want to consider how much
THC and CBD
is found in the stream generally you
will find most relief from a string that
has large quantities of both CBD and THC
with a high CBD THC ratio this is
because CBD can help to mediate the side
effects of THC while also providing
additional anti-inflammatory and
analgesic properties some researchers
have found that CBD may prove to combat
cancer authors of a review published in
the British Journal of clinical
pharmacology found evidence that CBD
significantly helped to prevent the
spread of cancer the researchers also
noted that the compound tends to
suppress the growth of cancer cells and
promote their destruction they pointed
out that CBD has low levels of toxicity
and they called for further research in
its potential as an accompaniment to
standard cancer treatments type 1
diabetes results from inflammation that
occurs when the immune system attacks
cells in the pancreas research published
in 2016
found that CBD may ease this
inflammation in the pancreas this may be
the first step in finding a CBD based
treatment for type 1 diabetes a paper
presented the same year in Lisbon
Portugal suggests that CBD may reduce
inflammation and protect against the
delay or development of type 1 diabetes
initial research published in the
Journal of Alzheimer's disease found CBD
was able to prevent the development of
social recognition deficit in its
participants
this means that CBD could help people in
the early stages of Alzheimer's keep the
ability to recognize the faces of the
people that they know this is the first
evidence that CBD may slow the
progression of Alzheimer's disease
across the board it would appear as
though CBD is a natural wakefulness
promoting compound because of this it
seems smart to recommend to take your
CBD supplement or full-spectrum hep
extract supplement in the morning so as
to keep you alert all day and not to
interfere with falling asleep
interesting enough when subjects do this
it appears that not only do they stay
alert and awake throughout the day
but they also fall asleep at night more
quickly without any additional sleep aid
and stay asleep longer this would appear
to be because CBD is known to modulate
the microglia activation of the
inflammatory cycle keeping your body in
a less inflamed state and lowering your
stress in a review of studies done on
chronic pain patients the reviewer found
adequate evidence to correlate CBD oil
consumption with improving multiple
sleep biomarkers including sleep onset
which is basically how quickly someone
falls asleep the study also saw
repeating incidents of lower dream
recall and CBD subjects which is very
interesting it's difficult to point to a
mechanism here since very little is
known about the nature of dreams in the
field of neuroscience however this does
point to the idea that dream recall may
be regulated by the endocannabinoid
system to some degree the same study
also saw a decrease in insomnia symptoms
among subjects it appears as though CBD
is positively correlated with improving
sleep patterns but funny enough not
actually by making you sleepy as it is a
wakefulness promoting agent and not a
sedative like THC in fact it appears to
promote sleep improvement due to the
fact that it can lower stress levels as
a powerful antioxidant where it benefits
controlling free radicals in induced
inflammation are well-documented this is
great news as you can consume your CBD
supplements in the morning to keep you
stress-free and relaxed but focused
throughout the day and then you may fall
asleep more quickly and stay asleep
longer throughout the night
using high CB low THC to help quitting
smoking some promising evidence suggests
that CBD may help people quit smoking
cigarettes a pilot study published in
addictive behaviors found that smokers
who used inhalers containing CBD smoked
fewer cigarettes than usual and had no
further cravings for nicotine a similar
review published in neuro therapeutics
found that CBD may be a promising
treatment for people with opioid
addiction disorders the researchers
noted that CBD reduced some symptoms
associated with substance use disorders
these included anxiety related symptoms
pain and insomnia more research is
necessary but these findings suggest
that CBD may help to prevent or even
reduce withdrawal symptoms children with
autism spectrum disorder seek
significant improvement in symptoms and
less reliance on other medications after
treatment with tecum ohlins ever deagle
medical cannabis as confirmed by a new
study published in scientific reports
the two-year study followed 188 children
with an average age of 13 diagnosed with
ASD the patients were treated with tecum
öhlins high CBD low THC medical cannabis
strains which have been specifically
cultivated and shown to provide symptom
relief for ASD and related conditions
with minimal psychoactive effect at the
study's outset the most common patient
symptoms were restlessness rage attacks
and agitation after six months of daily
cannabis treatment with at tecum olan's
clinics in israel 80 point 1 percent of
the patients reported improvement of
their symptoms with only with 30 point
one percent reporting significant
improvements other key findings included
of the 27 patients who had epilepsy 24
reported improved or disappearance of
symptoms 34 point four percent of
patients decreased other medications and
20 percent of patients stop using
anti-psychotic medication
autism is a leading condition of concern
worldwide so this study couldn't have
come at a better time says dr. Annabelle
manola PhD who is tecum olam scientific
director this data showed that autism
patients can improve their overall
quality of life
utilizing a high CBD low THC strain and
most importantly that young users can
safely and effectively benefit from
medical cannabis with the study cannabis
is shown to be an effective choice for
parents looking for the safest and most
neuroprotective treatment the
side-effects to cannabis treatment were
minimal the FDA recently approved
epidemics as a medication for children
with refractory Caeser disorders and the
DEA classified at the dialects sched as
a Schedule v substance on September of
2018 epidemics would surely command a
lot of off-label attention if not for
the potent price tag and just as surely
a huge unregulated market for hemp
derived CBD isolate will continue to
flourish in a tenuous legal environment
an already massive consumer demand for
CB products has far outpaced the
gathering of clinical data on
cannabinoid interactions with
pharmaceuticals for pain cancer autism
heart disease and many other chronic
ailments concerning the product that the
fda approved to treat two types of
epilepsy researchers noticed the
following adverse effects in clinical
trials liver problems symptoms related
to central nervous system such as
irritability and lethargy reduced
appetite gastrointestinal problems
infections rashes and other sensitivity
reactions reduce urination and breathing
problems the patient information leaflet
notes that there is a risk of worsening
depression or suicidal thoughts it is
important to monitor anyone who is using
this drugs for signs of mood changes
research suggests that a person taking
the product is unlikely to form a
dependency the long-standing Berry
to research is a Schedule one status of
cannabis a category reserved for
dangerous substances with no medical
value according to federal law but the
paucity of federally sanctioned clinical
research a consequence of cannabis
prohibition should not be an excuse for
physicians or patients to shun
non-lethal cannabinoid therapies which
show promise for a wide range of
conditions when drugs do not have FDA
approval it can be difficult to know
whether a product contains a safe or
effective level of CBD unapproved
products may not have the properties or
content stated on the package it is
important to note that researchers have
linked marijuana use during pregnancy to
impairments in the fetal development of
neurons regular use among teens is also
associated with concerning memory
behavior and intelligence CBD is just
one of the many cannabinoids found in
marijuana and it is not psychoactive
smoking cannabis is not the same as
using CBD oil and using CBD oil was not
the same as smoking cannabis a person
can use CBD oil in different ways to
relieve various symptoms if a doctor
prescribes it it's important to follow
their instructions CBD products come in
many forms some can be mixed into
different foods or drinks and taken with
a pipette or dropper others are
available in capsules or as a thick
paste to be massaged into the skin some
products are available as sprays to be
administered under the tongue
recommended dosages vary between
individuals and depend on factors such
as body weight the concentration of the
products and the health issue the
studies done on CBD oil have a pretty
wide dose range anywhere from a few
milligrams to hundreds of milligrams
it's suggested to start at the lower end
around 10 milligrams and slowly increase
over a few weeks or months to see what
works for you some people also do well
with splitting the dosage throughout the
day
instead of taking the dose all at once
it is always a good idea to talk with
your prescribing doctor if you are on
any medications CBD is generally very
safe but there are some pharmaceutical
medications it could potentially
interact with an increase or decrease
the pharmaceutical drugs effectiveness
some CBD manufacturers have come under
government scrutiny for wild and
defensible claims such as that CBD is a
cure-all for cancer we need more
research but CBD may prove to be an
option for managing anxiety insomnia and
chronic pain without sufficient high
quality evidence in human studies we
can't pinpoint effective doses and
because CBD is currently mostly
available as an unregulated supplement
it's difficult to know exactly what you
are getting if you decide to try CBD
check with your doctor if for no other
reason than to make sure it won't affect
other medications that you're taking
using CBD THC compounds in concert has
been shown to help mitigate side-effects
and enhance efficacy with CBD + THC
showing more benefit for some conditions
and THC alone studies have confirmed
that CBD helps to counteract some of the
sedative high feeling anxiety and rapid
heartbeat that's associated with THC
consumption it also has been found to
extend the half-life of the THC which
may help to extend the pain relieving
benefits this has allowed the use of
higher doses of THC in clinical trials
for the treatment of pain caused by
multiple sclerosis peripheral neuropathy
intractable cancer pain and rheumatoid
arthritis when used in concert a greater
efficacy in treating these types of pain
has been observed you may be wondering
what is the ideal balance a ratio of CBD
and THC every strain of Bud that you
purchased at a dispensary will be
labeled with its THC and CBD content
and that's helpful when choosing a
strain for pain relief thus far based on
the observations regarding the ride
spread use of cannabis flour and full
spectrum cannabis oil it does not appear
that there have been many problems
because of cannabinoid drug reactions to
the extent that there have been
problematic drug interactions with
cannabinoids these have involved high
doses of CBD isolates not cannabis in
general even though THC is an intoxicant
and CBD is not the fact that people tend
to use much higher doses of pure CBD
makes it much riskier player in the
metabolic drug interactions 10
milligrams of THC in a cannabis product
is a hefty dose for a naive patient and
sufficiently psychoactive for the
occasional recreational user 10
milligrams of THC combined with equal
amounts of CBD in a sativex tincture
hits the energies exploit spot in
clinical trials there are moderate doses
compared to the amount of single
molecule CBD administer to epileptic
children in clinical trials up to 50
milligrams per kilogram with CBD doses
as high as 2,000 milligrams not uncommon
among patients who obtain CBD isolates
from internet storefronts and other
unregulated sources THC has its own
built in guardrails consume too much and
you'll know you've hit your limit with
CBD there are no guardrails no dysphoric
feedback loop that says you've had
enough CBD is intrinsically safe but
when extracting from the plant and
concentrated as an isolate high doses
are necessary for therapeutic efficacy
unlike whole plant CBD rich extracts
which have a broader therapeutic window
and are effective at lower doses in a
single molecule CBD drug interactions
are much more likely with high dose CBD
therapy than other forms of cannabis
consumption physicians and patients
should be concerned about this given the
current regulatory regime with
privileges CBD isolates over artisanal
plant-derived multi-component
formulations the legality CBD is a
cannabinoid derived from the cannabis
plant cannabis is legal for either
medicinal or recreational use in use in
some American states other states have
approved the use of CBD oil as a hemp
product but not the general use of
medical marijuana some state and federal
laws differ and current marijuana and
CBD legislation in the United States can
be confusing even in states where
marijuana is legal there is an
ever-changing number of states that do
not necessarily consider marijuana to be
legal but have laws directly related to
CBD oil the following information is
accurate as as of May 2018 but the laws
change frequently however state
legislators usually approve the use of
CBD oil at various concentrations to
treat a range of epileptic conditions a
full list of states that have CBD
specific laws is available different
states also require different levels of
prescriptions to possess and use CBD oil
in Missouri for example a person can use
CBD of a particular composition if they
can show that three other treatment
options have failed to treat their
epilepsy they can provide information
about safe CBD sausage sources and local
laws surrounding uses anyone considering
CBD oil should speak with a local
healthcare provider it's also research
your local state laws most states
require a prescription my own state of
Delaware has a medical marijuana program
that currently has close to 7,000
patients thank you so much for watching
my webinar on high CBD low THC product
efficacy for better patient outcomes in
medical marijuana programs I'm Ruth
betrayin from Wyoming Delaware I have
worked as a nurse for the past 13 years
where I come face-to-face with various
disease processes daily I'm a member of
the American cannabis Nurses Association
Delaware normal and the Delaware
cannabis advocacy Network I have been an
advocate for marijuana since 1975 and
I've lobbied at state and national
levels for the past couple of years we
hope to legalize recreational cannabis
here in Delaware this year the
legislators in my state decide the fate
of marijuana so the only way to make
change is to speak to them personally
61% of Delaware again support
legalization of recreational cannabis I
am by no means an expert on this topic
but I recently worked in one of the
medical marijuana dispensaries here in
Delaware and I know of the pain and
suffering the patient's endure for years
before they finally get their doctor to
agree that marijuana could help it's my
hope that patients everywhere are able
to utilize marijuana as a first line of
defense in their medical treatment
instead of it being a last resort I'd
like to give a shout out to Jay and
Riley mendler of Riley sunshine and
thank them for all the hard work and
dedication and their continued support
of pediatric medical cannabis worldwide
I'd also like to thank Delaware Normal
and the Delaware cannabis advocacy
Network for the continued work towards
legalization I'm going to close with the
video done by a friend of mine
Tommy Lyons he is a veteran who lives in
Maryland and he's a medical marijuana
patient thank you for watching hey
everybody my name is Tommy Lyons and I'm
a good friend of Ruth wanted to come on
here today and talk to you about why I
use CBD products from the cannabis plant
specifically I'd like to state that I'm
not representing any industry and I'm a
registered and approved msec patient
which means I have safe access to
cannabis in Maryland
I'm a service-connected disabled veteran
and I use cannabis to offset various
symptoms that come along with that I
find that the CBD really helps target
the symptoms from PTSD major depressive
disorder and it helps me just kind of
regain my calm I enjoy ac/dc I'm
smoker and ac/dc is great it is very
high in CBD and almost next to nothing
in THC what that does for me is just
give me a clear slate just makes me feel
alright no high really but I'm not it's
hard to say the word high anymore
because it does different things for
everybody but what we're finding is that
the one thing it's doing across the
board is providing an increase in
quality of life and that's why I like
cannabis and CBD it is important to use
THC with the CBD to create what's called
the entourage effect that was explained
to me by a good friend of mine the old
buddy old pal bill that CBD Rides and
THC drives so you're in the car
you've got THC and CBD working together
CBD is kind of navigating telling the
THC where to go and then the THC is like
mmm just kind of takes off and then it's
like a little bit too much so the CBD is
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa come
back here come back here get back to the
speed limit so if you ever have too much
THC for any reason use some CBD the CBD
teamsters the drops that you put under
your tongue that's a great way to
medicate people are finding that to be
very effective as a source to get the
CBD into their system I usually
recommend a ten to one texture which is
ten part CBD and one part THC when it
comes to THC and CBD in regard to dosing
they're called Colorado doses ten
milligrams of THC is one Colorado dose
one milligram of CBD is one Colorado
dose you can have as much CBD as you can
intake you can't have too much CBD which
is great you can't have too much THC or
any other cannabinoid for that fact but
the more you intake of certain
cannabinoids the more potential you have
for psychotropic psychedelic effects
that you might not be looking for if
you're looking for medicinal relief in
regard to anxiety stress depression
cancer looking for tumor reduction
looking for symptom relief with HIV
ADEs gastrointestinal issues post
reconstructive surgery or any kind of
surgery for that matter there are bombs
THC and CBD bombs that are great for
spot application for example if you're
having elbow pain rub it right on the
elbow there are compounds that are
transdermally ingested so those are same
things bomb and if you're having spot
pain then you rub it on that and then
you always rub it on your wrist where
the skin is really thin and Venus
because the compounds can either be spot
application by themselves for spot
application with transdermal properties
so when it's transdermal and you rub it
on the thin part of the skin it's gonna
go full bloodstream which is going to
give you a better chance for relief and
fighting symptoms I've had a great
opportunity to learn about cannabis I
work as a dispensary technician at
nature's care and wellness I'm also a
patient consultant so I've worked with I
have 3,000 patients that come into the
store and I've gotten an opportunity to
work with most of them and what we do is
come up with plans in regard to how we
can help figure this out come together
get on a med excuse me get on a medical
regimen and then find relief and it's
working people keep coming back I've
been working with people for over a year
now and it works so it's really great to
see people coming back people getting
relief people's scams coming back clear
people are kicking opiates I mean from
going going from 280 milligrams a day
down to nothing cannabis it's not just
about the THC and CBD either
there are many cannabinoids there are
over 200 identified cannabinoids
there are also terpenes which is the
flavor and scent there's tart beans and
everything stripping's and oranges
tomatoes it's all over the place it's
plant-based wellness and bringing these
things together in an effort to find
wellness as possible so it's great there
are our CBD vapes CBD heavy vapes that
are cannabis for example some strains
that are really good are penny wise
hardly sue tsunami
harley quinn ac/dc shark shock blue
dream blue dream is my favorite I've
been using blue dream as my meds when I
smoke they're the prettiest CBD buds
I've ever seen and I mention that
because I get relief when I open the bag
smell it you know I take the milk out or
break it open and just looking at it
just makes me go I love that that's one
thing about cannabis that you're not
gonna get from any kind of prescription
medication you're never gonna open up a
bottle of pills and be like no it's just
it's not like that there are capsules
that you can ingest to get CBD and THC
into your system there's also RS o which
is Rick Simpson oil
another good strain what CBD is a ray of
sunshine and I've seen that in RSO tubes
with a thousand milligrams total
cannabinoids 600 milligrams CBD and 200
milligrams THC which is an amazing ratio
because that's not going to get you too
high but it is gonna get you some
serious medicinal relief especially
during the day the best way to consume
that is called front lining it's a term
that I coined basically dry out the
inside of your gum with a paper towel
have your meds ready pull the paper
towel out so it's dry line the gums with
the oil it's viscous and then let it sit
there before you know it it's full blood
streams called sublingual ingestion and
it's really helping people alright
everybody thank you so much for watching
my video if there's anything I can do to
help please let Ruth know and I'd be
happy to follow up again my name is
Tommy cannabis saves lives and that's
what it's all about
have a great day Thank You Ruth for that
informative presentation I'd also like
immigrants for making today's
educational webcast possible as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we'll see you next time